[Música]
quem está a fim de comprar um celular
supermoderno levanta a mão que celular
top iphone e android
acho que todo mundo tem um celular novo
né ou então uma viagem que vocês querem
fazer posterior aquele sonho antigo
vocês querem né
a boa viagem né pode ser legal sabia que
quem faz a venda pra vocês desse sonho é
um vendedor
olha que legal esse vendedor de
celulares também tem metas
o vendedor também de agência de viagem
também tem metas
só que agora parece que a hora que eu
falei pra vocês quando vocês vão fazer
essa compra é um momento divertido é
fazer esse tipo de compra né
e aí na verdade é isso que eu queria
contar pra vocês
e aí eu vou contar uma história tá eu
coloquei essa primeira provocação você
quer ser escolhido pra transformação e
aí nós vamos responder essa pergunta no
final dessa fala tá vai ser um desafio
enorme falar em pouco tempo porque eu
faço reuniões com a minha equipe todo
santo dia de mais ou menos uma hora todo
dia a justiça não cansa de falar não
bora lá eu procurei a origem etimológica
da palavra transformação e vi que era do
latim transformar em fazer mudar de
forma e de aspecto é trans através de
formar e dar forma aspecto molde
aparência eu sempre gosto de falar e com
usando a minha nova teoria da tpm eu vou
conseguir inserir várias coisas que eu
aprendi nesses últimos dez anos aqui pra
vocês
uma das coisas é o seguinte eu me
descobri como sendo uma pessoa
extremamente satisfeita
tudo que acontece na minha vida eu estou
satisfeito
porém eu não sou conformado
tá uma água quando você coloca num copo
o copo água assume a forma de então a
água ficou se conforma em qualquer
recipiente que colocasse concordam
então assim a água ela se conforma o ser
humano o ideal é que ele não se conforme
porém ele esteja sempre satisfeito bora
lá se vão me acompanhar
eu sou julho tem 32 anos sou casado com
aninha muito bem mencionados na
representação só de araxá minas gerais
apesar de residir em uberaba tá eu sou
contador e eu sou pós graduado em gestão
de pessoas tapetão
eu inclusive só é concursado públicos
foi gerente da caixa por sete anos
tá hoje eu sou empresário eu tenho
unidade da wise up uberaba desafio em
franca ea gente cuida da área comercial
também em uberlândia
hoje eu sou mentorado flávio alguns quem
conhece o flávio augusto da silva que
levantavam legal
então eu sou defensor do
empreendedorismo como estilo de vida tá
e agora nós vamos falar um pouco mais
sobre empreendedorismo na antiga na
palha na primeira palestra o georges
falou muito bem sobre empreendedorismo
na primeira e aí eu queria mostrar pra
vocês a primeira empresa que eu abri
quem tem essa empresa que levanta a mão
de ver mais gente para poder enxergar se
conhece essa empresa né
tira lá no ministério do trabalho né
e olha que legal essa primeira empresa
que abriu ainda tinha cabelo né
eu fui lá no ministério trabalho abre
essa empresa e aí tá ali minha primeira
empresa dia 25 de fevereiro dia 25 de
fevereiro chorando aqui que é mais fácil
de 2004
eu tinha um excelente salário de
duzentos e quarenta e cinco reais por
mês nessa época essa empresa ela manteve
as estatísticas do brasil ela quebrou no
primeiro ano está a maioria das empresas
quebram no primeiro ano no brasil
eu também quebrei minha primeira empresa
no primeiro ano lá entrei em fevereiro e
já em novembro do mesmo ano em baixa
empresa de sucesso nela
bora lá depois que eu fui cotadores
supermercado eu fui auxiliar de
escritório
o antigo futebol né office boy no banco
e tal
entrei em março de 2005 essa empresa
abril e maio de 2005 e eu saí eu ganhava
260 reais por mês hoje melhorei né já
consegui ganhar um pouco melhor e sair
dessa empresa em agosto de 2005 quebrar
de novo antes do primeiro ano
tá bora lá continuar aqui é só essa
história que o que falou na na minha
entrada eu fui vendedor de pista
frentista foi frentista engraçado que
essa palavra que eu falei pra vocês no
começo já estava aqui ó vendedor
apesar de eu nunca me considerei me
considerar um vendedor e isso tem um
pouco a ver com a história que nós vamos
contar nesse momento eu comecei uma
outra história
quero entender um pouco mais sobre fé tá
até aqui não é só a fé religiosa quando
você vai você precisa da fé pública em
um documento você vai num cartório né
e esse cartório não tem nada de
religioso né então assim tomar fé
pública de algo significa acredite que é
verdadeiro não é eu também queria falar
um pouquinho de uma história de fé com
vocês tá vendedor de pista 360 trezentos
e cinquenta reais por mês ganhava tinha
a 30% de adicional de periculosidade a
empresa começou a ganhar bem mas o mais
legal dessa história a gente não é isso
o mais legal é que nessa época eu
aprendi que eu não podia falar tudo que
eu queria tá eu aprendi que eu tinha que
parar em algum emprego e esse foi um
grande aprendizado porque precisava
parar quieta em algum lugar gente alguém
aqui já se sentiu perdido alguma vez
levantavam prover não se ou seja alguém
que conhece então tem que chegar lá ele
se sentiu perdido de ilegal
então o seguinte galera vendedor de
pista me descobrir que tudo que eu
quiser fazer bem feito eu consigo tá e
aí eu fui frentista eu fui eu fui
subindo de carla no la nesse posto de
gasolina em araxá né
e eu consegui ficar nesse cargo de abril
de 2006 até novembro de 2008
eu fugi das estatísticas sejam guardar
essa informação está de olhos legal nem
como vendedor
aqui só chegando mais perto aqui no
slide não vai fazendo vai ter
necessidade da gente falar sobre ele e
aqui a foto que prova que eu inventei a
celso no espelho e celular
do lado assim ele era bem legal eu não
sei lá mas eu inventei a celpe mesmo um
potente e tá então assim apesar de tudo
as coisas estarem difícil lá em casa né
eu mantinha esse sorriso no rosto no
posto eu aprendi a começar a querer ter
uma empresa que progride nem que têm
sucesso tá e aí eu já estava no posto
mas hoje assumir algum cargo um pouco
mais gerencial até aqui eu já aprendi
alguns conceitos básicos que venda não é
uma coisa ruim que tudo o que você puder
o que você quiser fazer agora se você
fizer bem feitas e vai ter sucesso
eu costumo brincar com a minha equipe o
seguinte se você vender picolé muito bem
vendido
você vai ter uma empresa do nível
uma empresa do tipo que bom né você vem
de triunfo na páscoa muito bem vendido
você vai virar uma cacau show né
então assim que eu queria trazer pra
vocês nesse ponto transformação pra mim
é algo que desde quando eu nem entendi o
que quer e empreendedorismo
eu já vivenciaram isso né e hoje
empreendedorismo pra mim é muito mais do
que abrir um cnpj e nós vamos falar
disso também tá essa foto apesar da
montagem super moderna da época do
fotolog do orkut não sei se vão lembrar
disso né é uma frota de 28 de dezembro
de 2008 quando eu conheci a minha
namorada
tá você vê que eu tinha lhe um aspecto
interessante bom né brinca né
então assim essa moça ela foi
responsável pela grande transformação da
minha vida porque teve um momento na
minha vida que eu só precisava que
alguém que confiassem mim porque
potencial eu até tinha já tinha
potencial mas eu não tinha rumo né
você pode gastar muita energia para
alguma coisa mas se você não tiver um
rumo não adianta correto possa ser forte
voz e inteligente o suficiente posso ter
poder de impacto mas eu não sei onde
quero chegar
não adianta eu tenho esse nível de
impacto e aí no em 2008 aconteceu um
negócio que se eu voltar que vão
perceber eu saí do posto em novembro de
2008 e foi a primeira vez que eu tive
consciência de que eu não precisava ser
mandado embora da empresa podia pedir
conta
olha que legal ganhei uma nova super
poderosa e eu sou o dono do meu destino
eu vou trabalhar onde eu quiser né
e aí com esse coincidentemente depois
que eu saí do posto
eu conheci a ana um mês depois
depois de um ano ela e ajudando me
direcionando emendando algumas dicas que
ela aprendeu com a vida dela sempre foi
muito madura apesar da idade a gente já
tem mais de dez anos juntos
então assim ela me direcionou de uma
certa forma que eu fazia um monte de
coisas ao mesmo tempo porém nada com
muita energia e muito foco então que eu
pensei telefone e me ajuda que ia
superar esses desafios a gente falou de
desafios e obstáculos já concordamos que
todo mundo tem obstáculos e eu tinha os
meus obstáculos inclusive eram
financeiros
tinha doenças graves na família então
assim nessa época a minha mãe vendeu a
idéia de que eu podia focar em um
concurso público
foi aí que eu passei no concurso da
caixa é um concurso de mais de 15 mil
pessoas
eu estava entre os 20 primeiros né aqui
dessa história como a gente tem menos
tempo do que do que para conseguir
contar toda eu vou resumir houve um
salto quântico na minha vida depois de
2008 2008
eu fiquei 2009 aprendendo que eu era
capaz de 2010 eu passei no concurso
público
em dezembro eu entrei eu fiquei dois
anos dois anos nesse concurso é e aqui
nessa foto tirada nessa bobeira de usar
um óculos escuro à noite né
essa foto conta muito do que aconteceu
na minha vida depois que eu entendi o
que eu tinha na minha mão
muita coisa porque vocês acreditam gente
como eu falei que eu contar uma história
que esta foto eu já estava na caixa já
tinha dois anos
a minha esposa tinha acabado de passar
no concurso ea gente estava junto eu
comecei a namorar com ela os dois fora
do banco e aqui nós dois
dentro do banco aí vocês vão entender
porque é que eu falei que eu sou
vendedor porque graças a deus né eu
falei esses dias na rádio nem e e deus
me presenteou com não ter oportunidade
de falhar porque lá em casa ou eu dava
certo ou eu dava certo eu não tinha a
segunda opção
então quando chega nessa fase gente eu
consegui entender que venda é uma
habilidade que toda pessoa precisa ter
seja para vender uma coisa seja para
vender um projeto seja para conquistar
alguma coisa seja pra você convencer um
amigo sair com você hoje à noite na
exposição de vender
tá e aí nessa foto eu entendi que eu
conseguia vender bem um projeto e aí
essa foto estava nós dois já
funcionários públicos em 2012
e aí a gente conseguiu comprar nossa
primeira casa em uberaba
a gente conseguiu comprar nosso carro
conseguiu ter as coisas né que todo
casal recém-casado que ter né
e aí é essa foto já é outro salto
quântico sua foto já era gerente essa
galera ia da minha equipe de uma
cidadezinha lá perto de ituiutaba
a gente estava num churrasco eu estava
me despedindo
por que essa foto já eu já estava sendo
promovido teve uma época da minha vida
pessoal de 2012 pra frente que todo ano
eu era promovido
baseado em quê no que eu aprendi no
posto a tudo que aprendi no posto e
replicado aqui e aí quem conhece esse
prédio que já foi em brasília trabalha
na matriz do da caixa econômica em
brasília a primeira vez que eu fui a
brasília ea segunda vez que eu fui pro
brasil está aqui tá aqui que a televisão
paga
então o pessoal seguinte eu tinha uma
carreira de sucesso
só que lembrar naquele momento que eu
pedi conta do posto teve uma situação na
minha cabeça que mexeu muito comigo que
era o que sabe o que é que me
desmotivava eu sei igual nesse momento é
igual a água eu conformar com a forma
que eles estão querendo colocar sabe
quando eu passei no concurso quem é que
nunca escutou tem algum conquistado que
levantavam deixa o governo tem
conquistado quando eu passei no concurso
minha mãe falou assim graças a deus você
vai aposentar no concurso né
eu peguei e falei mas como assim será
que eu tenho eu tenho que ficar né
engraçado a gente escuta na história né
a última explica que foi os bombeiros
hoje eu consigo ser várias e várias
profissões que eu sonhava e hoje eu
também resgatando vidas
hoje eu também vou lá na periferia
buscar pessoas que acha que não consegue
fazer nada tira ela da lama e faz ela
crescer as pessoas é essa semana tive
emoção muito grande na empresa que
quatro ou cinco pessoas que nunca tinha
declarado imposto de renda agora começou
declarar
e aí nós estamos entrando e olha que
isso tudo que eu tô falando de vendas
estão assim pessoal
voltando o que é que me desmotiva as
empresas a falta de lugar para aí a
falta de não me conformar a falta de
lugar para crescer o plano de carreira é
hoje atrai muita gente quando fala plano
de carreira né
então assim quando eu via que já não
depende mais de mim eu ficava chateada
né hashtag chateado e sair falava assim
o quer sair aconteceu no banco uma coisa
muito interessante eu adorava o banco
hoje eu sou grata à caixa econômica
federal por tudo que ela me presenteou
hoje eu sou fruto do que eu aprendi lá
net gestão de liderança tudo mais porém
o entende algo é teve um momento que eu
pegava o meu holerite que já era um
salário que eu nunca pensava que eu
ganhei na vida né
e começava a me achar um pouco egoísta
sabe por que eu falava assim poxa
aprender as coisas tão rápido
será que o objetivo da minha vida é só
fazer o que eu faço hoje né e olha que
agora nós estamos entrando temos vendas
de transformação tá eu comecei a pensar
para e dá pra fazer mais próximo para
fazer um pouco mais né
e aí eu decidi que eu saí do banco no
ápice da minha carreira estava sendo
promovido já para uma para um cargo
acima do que eu estava e eu decidi sair
e isso tem mais ou menos um ano que eu
fiz o que me motivou a fazer isso além
dessa questão de querer fazer mais
próximo de querer me livrar de algumas
amarras né
foi descobrir essa diferença aqui ó a
diferença de chefe e de líder
tá então assim eu entendi que existiam
algumas poucas pessoas que não é
atributo de multidões
tá mas eu entendi que existiam líderes
no mercado pessoas que sabe quando
cheguei às pessoas escondendo a sala
geralmente é assim né
mas eu descobri que tinha pessoas que as
pessoas queriam estar perto os donos de
grandes empresas são poucas as pessoas
que não está perto mas eu perguntei do
flávio alguns porque eu quis me
aproximar e agora nós vamos voltar no
ponto eu falei pra vocês sobre fé sabe
que eu acredito que é fé é você
acreditar que vai existir uma coisa que
ainda não existe você vai fazer todo o
esforço possível para que exista e é
isso que eu entendi como fé e aí tem
duas pt tem duas né eu não sei se vou
conseguir definir isso como coisas como
algo mas tem duas coisas que não podem
perder a fé é a primeira em deus ou na
física quântica que se quiser chamar ou
no criador e na segunda coisa que eu
acho que muita gente esquece quem você
aí você acreditar que você consegue
realizar qualquer coisa eu li um livro
na minha cama e uberlândia e percebi que
eu queria chegar perto de da pessoa
escrever esse livro
e aí eu abrir uma escola vendi minha
casa
vendi meu carro sai do meu cargo público
e descobri que tinha uma uma forma de eu
conhecer
agradecer esse escritor por tudo que ele
fez na minha vida através das palavras
do livro gente senão a de ver que eu
conheci esse aqui é o cara
flávio augusto da silva periferia do rio
de janeiro comprou um time de futebol
orlando é uma boa história
não vou conseguir contar agora e aí
quando eu peguei aqui ó
os escolhidos para a transformação tem
uma frase e quem já escuta essa frase
vai saber de onde ela vem mas tem uma
frase sempre que fala assim muitos são
chamados e poucos são os escolhidos
sáb e essa frase ela me toca muito sabe
porquê porque é esse o tema que eu
queria trazer para vocês vocês seja
estudar essa frase né
mas chamado a maioria é muito são
chamados
agora a escolha a gente tem que fazer a
gente se a gente não se escolhe ninguém
escolhe pela gente já vem quando você
tira uma self a primeira pessoa que você
olha na selva é você reparar isso e aqui
se estão vendo é um empreendedor de
palco
vocês estão vendo o empreendedor no
palco a isso não têm dificuldade de
falar aqui e aí eu vou finalizar com
essa fala do flávio que é o meu mentor
que a pessoa que eu fiquei amigo né que
é um bilionário acessível que muita
gente queria só chega na frente dele
agradeceu o que é que um livro mudou na
vida dele
agora imagina você terá acesso direto e
ele escreveu numa internet onde o que
mais tenha empreendedor de palco que
fala só sobre o que nunca viveu
agora temos como julho que vive cada
palavra que fala eo melhor com
autoridade no assunto
ele deixou a estabilidade tão sonhada
para empreender e teve sucesso
posso dizer que julho é um dos melhores
empreendedores da nossa rede
aí vai pra onde o filme você quer ser
escolhido transformação 1
eu quero eu confio assistir palestra
achar bonito é lindo gente mas se você
não fizer por você
ninguém vai fazer ninguém muito obrigado
[Música]